I've always loved real estate I loved it
since I was a young guy it was the way I
was born it's in my blood you know the
the real business
that we're in is the hospitality
business so we're in the business of
making people happy and part of that is
the retail business because we can
create these incredible centers like to
grow over the Americana and people come
and they can hang out with their family
and they can grab a bite the keys to the
Grove success is we reflect this
neighborhood we reflect the community
around us that that we become part of
the fabric of Los Angeles there's a
timeless quality to it as a there's a
comfort there's a sense of happiness
when you step on the property
brick-and-mortar retail is alive and
well if you have the right
brick-and-mortar retail it's like any
category of any business you have to be
current you have to be relevant you have
to be efficient and productive but the
main thing in retail is you have to be
meaningful to somebody and so what's
happened in retail is it evolves quickly
and it's evolving quicker now than it
ever has before a lot of retailers
haven't evolved as quickly as they
should and they become irrelevant to the
consumer to their guests but
brick-and-mortar in and of itself I
think is great when people say online
retail is going to put brick and mortar
out of business online retail is going
to put bad brick and mortar out of
business and it should put it out of
business the indoor mall is an
anachronism that is going to continue to
fail because it's disconnected with how
people want to live their life people by
their very nature organically don't want
to walk inside a place and spend the day
and shop right and that's why open-air
properties are streets in particular
have always outperformed the indoor
malls so I think if you build brick and
mortar that people feel connected to
that retailers can create a great
experience inside their four walls and
you build an environment that people
want to come not just a shop but just to
hang out and enjoy themselves
I think it's great the real-estate
landscape in five or ten years is going
to continue to involve more and more of
the digital retailers online retailers
are going to convert and they're gonna
open up brick-and-mortar stores you see
that happening now you got Amazon books
now right which is the irony
you see Warby Parker was online and now
they're opening up stores what I see
evolving is going back to what always
worked
having retail close to home that is
relevant to your lifestyle that's
comfortable that is scaled right that
relates to you as a human being one of
the problems in the real estate industry
as many people build off a spreadsheet
they build off a pro-forma and they
start justifying a project based on the
numbers we don't do that we start out
and we say what is the community need
what do they want what are the retailers
need how are we going to drive sales how
are we gonna be productive how are we
gonna create this great environment we
put that together and then we put the
numbers to that and we say can we make
sense out of this we're doubling down
because our growth is exceptional we're
having the best year ever
so our business has grown about 20%
compounded annual growth every year for
25 years so we're doubling down because
we're building on the success that we
have we're building on what we know do
you wake up in the morning and say you
know what I'm gonna go meet a couple of
friends and hang out at the Grove today
it's just gonna be a cool place to go if
I get you to say that if my property is
part of your daily routine in some form
or fashion we did our job
[Music]